for
good afternoon everyone and wel welcome
I'm Jack Van Horn from the University of
Virginia I'm very proud to welcome you
to this edition of our 2023 2024
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA College of Arts and
Sciences the UVA School of data science
and through a grant from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences
since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series has focused
on the use of data science methodologies
artificial intelligence
deep learning and statistical modeling
as they pertain to differing themes in
the biomedical and Health Sciences our
theme this year is focused on building
Partnerships for generative AI training
in biomedical and clinical research
where every Friday we enjoy lectures
from a wide array of leading thinkers on
the issues promise opportunities and
hurdles associated with the emerging
wavefront of AI based methods
participants selected for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab program will
leverage these seminar presentations as
vital material for a culminating
in-person manuscript and Grant
development project Workshop to be held
at the bajia beachfront Resort in Sunny
San Diego California in June of 2024 we
are excited for this year's exciting and
engaging program where we're bringing
together um Junior faculty who are AI
platform developers biomedical
researchers and University level
Educators to better understand the power
promise and potential pitfalls
associated with the generative AI
explosion today's speaker I am delighted
to to say is uh uh my neighbor in the
school of the Department of psychology
Dr Steven Boker from the University of
Virginia Stephen is Professor of
quantitative psychology and data science
and directs the human dynamics
laboratory and the Life Academy here at
the University of Virginia he is
internationally recognized as an expert
in the modeling of longitudinal data
using dynamical systems analysis and as
one of the core developers of the open
MX structural equation modeling software
program his current research involves
applying uh psychometric methods to
understanding the behavior of generative
large language models from a
psychological perspective and in
continuing our 2023 2024 biomedical data
science seminar series theme Steve's
lecture today is entitled psychometrics
at large language models what can be
learned and what can go wrong Steve is
going to note that natural the natural
human response to language is to engage
the theory of mind and understand the
inner state of our conversational
Partners he's going to propos that
methods developed to discern individual
difference characteristics such as
personality and emotion uh from the
semantic structure of language can be
usefully applied to generative linear uh
large language models to understand the
meaning expressed by them an example of
this will be uh applied to a chat GPT
where he is going to describe how the
semantic structure of the language
describing personality has similarities
and yet differences to real life humans
uh this is very important because when
we're dealing with uh generative large
large language models at the their rate
of text streams and differences in
meaning may be misinterpreted by the
humans receiving them as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for
recording via YouTube and if you are
watching on YouTube thank you so much
for joining us also our specially
selected 2023 2024 by medical data
science Innovation lab participants and
alumni are encouraged to submit any
questions by the chat feature in their
YouTube sessions I will be synthesizing
these questions and asking them on your
behalf during the last 10 minutes or so
of the lecture and with that Steve
welcome I am very very excited to hear
about your research and to hear about
the uh your from you uh uh during your
presentation so thank
you well thank you for the kind uh
introduction Jack um today uh I'm going
to be talking about uh large language
models and how we might uh use tools
from psychometrics to understand their
behavior um so chat GPT is a generative
large language model these are deep
learning neural networks and they're
trained on billions uh of words of human
generated
text um and as Jack mentioned theory of
mind is what we call the prediction of
another person's thoughts uh or emotions
um it's what we use to understand what
other people are thinking um and
sometimes
uh it's difficult to tell whether Chachi
BT is a person or a machine
and that is theory of mind at work um
language tells us something about
whoever generated the language um but G
uh glm chat GPT is not a person it just
predicts the next word it will type now
well just uh it's that's that's pretty a
pretty complicated thing to do um
however it's important we understand how
we're going to interpret glm
output um back in
1952 uh toring um wrote uh an important
feature of a learning machine is that a
teacher uh its teacher will often be
largely ignorant of quite what is going
on inside although he may still be able
to some extent predict his pupil's
behavior now this is a very preent uh um
statement um from what 70 some years ago
um but that's exactly what we'll plan to
do we'll try to uh predict behavior um
and interpret Behavior using uh
statistics and methods such as
factor analysis and inventories of um
personality or attitudes values biases
and so forth um that we've developed to
uh understand each other to understand
humans um now do I think that that chat
GPT is a human no of course not it's
it's just not it's it's a large language
model it predicts the next word
um however since it was trained on human
uh language that means that it's
um it embodies what we are to some in
some sense uh in the way that our
language is structured um and a a
characteristic like personality can
emerge um from language um um
and where did where did the idea of
Personality um come from uh well um the
um the the basic idea was people would
ask questions that had to do with what
they thought personality might be um and
then from these questions
they uh distilled a set of smaller and
smaller set of questions to to
understand how we differ from each other
in
personality um so so let's look at uh
let's look at what a large language
model is uh at the base it's a um it's a
deep learning neural network uh deep
learning refers to having hidden layers
in this in the network um and many
hidden layers um
and a famous uh a famous proof uh by
korov um uh suggests or says that any
input output relationship can be uh
approximated um if there are sufficient
numbers of hidden layers in in a system
like this and so this this is sort of
the promise of of deep learning that
that there's a way to get from input to
Output um now a large language model uh
is an example of something called a
Transformer model Transformer model uh
is a recent development
2017 it was proposed by the folks at
Google
uh vaswani was the the uh person who was
the lead of that group um and it uses
something called multihead
attention um and in this in
this uh structure or
architecture um three things happen
first an input text string is split into
what's called tokens and they are they
could be single words or more than one
word um and then converted to what's
called a word embedding vector and this
is a this is a big step um uh the word
embedding Vector takes into account
what's what the word is relative to
other words around it um to other words
similar in meaning um and at each layer
we have this layered uh set of hidden
layers in in the network at each layer
there's an intention mechanism which
upweight important tokens um and there
may be thousands of layers um in a
Transformer
model um this kind of model learned much
faster and learns much faster than uh
other models that were out at the time
uh convolution networks or recurrence
networks um and so that meant that with
the same computer hardware we could uh
learn much larger networks and
uh again going back to Turing and his uh
uh machine intelligence article in
1950 um he suggested that there would be
something like um an atomic pile where
once you got a critical Mass together
emergent properties would happen and
that's exactly what's happened in uh you
know with chat gbt um there's there's
apparent understanding of language well
I say apparent because it's not
understanding in the way that we
understand things but it is in a sense
understanding
um okay so starting with word embedding
the basic idea is we code words by the
probability of their co-occurrence with
other words um and this this ends up
creating a space um a vector space where
if I had a three-dimensional space it
would be X Y and Z you know and then I
would put a point in the space and we
would be in three-dimensional space But
Here we have uh the uh the vector ctors
are ordered lists of numbers that
represent tokens or words um and the
that means that once you have a set of a
100 or a thousand you know some large
number of of numbers in this Vector then
it's a 100 dimensional space or a
thousand dimensional space and you get a
point someplace in that thousand
dimensional space and that is what this
word means right now relative to the
other words around it um its meaning can
change based on context and that's
important because because words change
their meanings uh depending on what
where they are in a sentence or a
document um okay so the uh this
Transformer model um optimizes in uh
in its learning there's a query at each
layer there's a query that's the thing
that's coming in and there's a key
that's the thing that's being paid
attention to and values and each of
those are vectors and the values are the
things that are learned um they're the
weights um and layers are composed of
alternating attention and feed forward
sublayers okay so this is a lot of this
is a lot of stuff but um what does it
what does it really mean um well it
means that that when you get a large uh
a large Transformer Network um you can
extract the linguistic
information and the attention part of
the attention Network can sort of focus
the network into uh into different kinds
of meanings meanings that are hopefully
appropriate to the
query um and finally at the last layer
there these uh vectors are are um are
converted into probabilities of the next
token it that will be produced the next
word um here's a visualization of a very
small Network um I say very small it's a
thou
8,800 parameters are being shown here um
and there are 11 heads that's the
columns and eight rows here um and
that's the layers um so there's 11 11 uh
heads attention heads that are being
read going down through the layers um
well what's going on there uh the the
visualization doesn't actually help all
that much although it's pretty but it
doesn't help me understand at least
exactly what's going on in this
network um well here's another here's
another way to think about the network
as uh we have a query coming in uh and
maybe I'm just going to give it two
words it was um and then it tries to
predict the next word goes through and
and a variety of things could happen um
maybe the next the most probable next
word is the or and the you know next
most probable word is uh and a very low
probability word is brilic right but
each one of these ends ends up uh in my
in my little example here in some kind
of literature could be it was the night
before Christmas or it was the best of
times worst of times um it was a dark
and stormy night okay so it's not all
great literature uh it was a perfect
storm um and you can see that that there
is this Divergence that can happen um
and this is this Divergence of how far
off into sort of into space uh a
particular query could go
um is called perplexity this this
Divergence is called
perplexity um
and if we have very very low perplexity
then only the top uh only the top most
likely word uh is is picked um as the
perplex perplexity grows then this fan
out can occur and you know any query
with high perplexity any query could
result in any kind of
output
um
okay so so we have here we have this
visualization of 8,800 parameters um
well GPT 35 has 100 more than 100
billion parameters and uh GPT 4 has
something like a trillion per parameters
um the visualization is probably not
going to help that much um and uh even
with a small perplexity it's you know
it's going to be really difficult to try
to trace all of the potential outcomes
so tracing the outcomes is not going to
help us so how do we how do we measure
the
behavior Well we'd like to measure it in
a human interpretable way we'd like to
have it be something that that is
Meaningful to us um and uh psychometric
instruments were designed to do that for
humans and humans you know they they
have very high
perplexity um and uh more than trillions
of
parameters um in the brain so so we've
already been doing this um so let's use
these kinds of
tools um
okay so now what what kind of what kind
of uh psychometric tools might we use um
we could for instance we could think
about cognitive abilities cognitive
abilities tests have been around since
uh what I think
1912 was the first you know the first
real uh intelligence test with a factor
analysis behind it uh coming up with
this idea that there is general
intelligence um so we could ex we could
estimate the extent of cognitive ability
and there are standardized test f um and
well maybe we could give these tests to
to
GPT ah but there may be a problem there
um the glm may have the test Bank in its
training data this is this could be a
problem so you know is this telling us
about the intelligence of the of the
machine not really um uh it's telling us
something about the training
data um we could also we could estimate
cognitive biases that is to say whether
an entity makes systematic mistakes and
that's that's really that might be
really useful um so uh
so our uh AI assistants are starting to
make
decisions um or to provide decision
support we would certainly want to know
if that decision had built into it a
bias where the bias came from the text
on which it was trained um if if I'm
having
if I'm an oncologist and the system is
making some sort of recommendation for
treatment I would like to know if there
is some kind of systematic bias in that
decision making um and that's something
that we can probe with psychometric
methods um and maybe uh we can take
control of that um it's pretty clear
that um the what what is attended to by
the system comes from the prompts that
it's given um and so that means that um
if I uh reord my prompt I may expose one
kind of bias or another so it might be
really useful to understand these biases
so that we can word our prompts in such
a way to make them less
biased um okay
so we also can uh inquire and another
cognitive abilities kind of cognitive
abilities task uh we inquire how an
ability is manifested that is to say you
know how does the brain work um how does
this ability relate to other abilities
that's that's generally the way that
this kind of question is structured um
well this this may also have a problem
uh in that um the uh the glm the the
large language model may have a
different organization of abilities than
humans and so this is actually this is
uh if we use the words that we
generally use to describe human
abilities we might lead ourselves astray
thinking that something is happening
that isn't or something isn't happening
that is so I think it's important here
to remember that that the glm may have a
very different organization of abilities
than humans and even though it's useful
to to give these kinds of uh these kinds
of tests
um it's uh we have to be careful about
interpreting what comes
back
um so uh Vincent Schulz uh in a article
last year which I would very uh you know
I recommend you read if you're
interested in this kind of uh if you're
interested in this kind of testing uh
they went through a whole variety of
cognitive abilities um started with
things uh the tests that are vignette
based that is to say you're uh you give
the the person or the machine um a small
paragraph and then ask them to make a
decision and this can frequently can
expose cognitive
biases um
uh the problem there is that most of
those tests that are that are uh
um where we know what is happening with
humans the reason we know what is
happening with humans is because they
have been given to large numbers of
people and that test then is very likely
to have been published someplace in a
scientific article and it is likely that
that test has been learned by the uh by
the large language model and so the
it's not doing the same thing in the uh
human and in the uh in the
machine uh and this can be exposed by
showing that small changes in a vignette
can lead to very different outcomes you
know where you think the machine is
biased in one way or has no bias then
you ask the question again just
rewarding it and then it shows something
entirely different well this is this is
a suggestion that that first question
the way it was originally worded was
probably part of the training
set um classical decision tasks are also
used um this is uh goes back to Conan
and tersi um and uh by increasing the
perplexity that is to say how how much
Divergence this is something you can set
in chat GPT how much Divergence do I
want they call this parameter
temperature um how much Divergence do I
want well if I if I allow some
Divergence then there's a chance for the
machine to start making mistakes um it
has it goes down a whole variety of
different paths within its uh within its
structure
um again small changes in the task can
lead to large differences and outcomes
but there's a distribution of mistakes
and that's the same kind of thing that
we like to see in humans we we try to
understand a distribution of mistakes
sometimes they get get it right
sometimes they don't if we can predict
what when they get it wrong with
something else then we've learned
something about the kinds of mistakes
that they make
um another kind of task that is uh
frequently used is called uh uh
exploration
exploitation um so that is to say how
often do I go out uh and I've learned
something and I stick with it because
I've learned it and I know what the
answer is and so I just keep sticking
with it whereas like maybe here's my
restaurant that I my favorite restaurant
in Charlottesville so I keep going to
that favorite restaurant but maybe
there's even even a better restaurant
out there so what do we what do I do
well maybe I just randomly go pick
another restaurant this is called uh
random uh random
exploration um and then there's another
kind of of uh exploration called
directed exploration and this is kind of
like using Yelp or something uh you know
some assistant to to look at reviews and
go try restaurants in a more directed
way so exploration exploitation can be
uh measured in GPT and has done they did
it pretty well Benson's Schultz did it
pretty well in this article um again
though small changes in the task can
lead to large differences in outcomes so
some of this has probably been learned
by the
machine uh causal reasoning can be
explored um so there's a difference
between if I have three variables x y
and z um and it could be that X is
causing Y which causes Z or it could be
that y causes both x and z um a common
cause or a causal chain
and diff uh understanding the difference
between these two kinds of causal uh
structures is is really uh you know it's
important if you're going to be a
scientist but also it's a source of many
mistakes even among scientists I have to
say this is one thing that that uh where
people often get things wrong um and
when the when the uh task is structured
uh like the classical versions of this
tasks the the the glm will will make
mistakes that are very similar to the
ones humans make but if you start to to
uh rearrange the task a little bit then
it starts to make mistakes in ways that
are just not humanlike at all um and so
uh and so there's clearly there's
something that has already been learned
uh about this
test um well there's another kind of of
uh psychometric inventory that we could
give um and that's for or non-cognitive
characteristics things like personality
values morals uh attitudes emotions um
and these uh certainly words for these
kinds of ideas personality or attitudes
morals um are going to be in the
training data and so they've been
learned um uh
however uh if you try to ask uh uh chat
gbt 35 or four it has guard rails uh put
in to prevent it from answering
questions about itself non-cognitive
aspects of
itself um prior to that uh it would it
would answer um but uh but now um that
it has been prevented from answering
these kinds of questions but there's
ways around it prompt engineering we can
we can find ways around it um okay so
now I'm going to focus on uh for the
next 20 minutes on
personality um and and give an example
um here's an example from my own
research um uh of the use of of
psychometrics um with a large language
model uh personalities uh the idea of
personality has been around for a very
long time um and it was uh began to be
measured scientifically in the uh 50s
and 60s and there was a big argument at
the time whether uh when we used a
personality inventory were we understand
what were we understanding what were we
exposing were we finding the semantic
structure of the words we were using um
you know there's a semantic Network out
there this is the sort of the word
embedding idea um and uh were we finding
this semantic Network or were we finding
individual differences in people uh and
their personality traits and this is
this was a uh you know this was a big
argument that ended up in the
methodology literature producing a
variety of of advances because they
tried to figure out well you know which
is it what are we trying what are we
actually learning here are we learning
Linguistics or are we learning about
people um well the answer is clearly yes
um both
um uh well at the time they couldn't
really resolve the argument because all
of the data were from Human participants
if you're going to use language you're
you're talking to people and people are
responding back to you um and so uh you
know was it people or was it language we
couldn't tell the difference uh but now
we can measure semantics a semantic
Network independent of of human
respondents and we can find out sort of
how much of the idea of personality is
embedded in the language that we use you
know and but you have to ask okay so
where did that Network that structure
come from
well it in terms of Personality
adjectives well it probably came about
because there's differences between
people and we needed a word to have a
you know a word for something like uh
you know talkative this person is more
talkative than that person well okay so
um uh I'm thinking now about myself am I
being talkative normally I'm not um are
you an extrovert are you not well
extroversion
that concept is a word that was made up
to to sort of give an idea of what the
what the axis is in this semantic space
where PE when people differ they differ
on a lot of different words
simultaneously um and this is you know
that's this axis say
extraversion um so uh
if I'm going toward talkativeness I'm
going away from
shyness um for instance so so there's
this sort of this idea of some axis
through the semantic Network well this
is something we can we can measure um in
chat GPT so we can understand a little
better what the semantic network is that
it's using um okay so uh how do we
measure personality well we give people
these these uh tasks where they where
you say well in general um I am uh and
there might be
there's some number of adjectives the
the a small number the many markers of
the big five that's 40 adjectives so
with 40 questions you can kind of get an
idea aide of what a person a person or
how a person perceives
themsel um or you could
ask a friend to uh to rate the
personality of their friend um and so it
could be you're rating the personality
of someone else um and this these are
these are ways that we understand
personality and there's five different
dimensions five different axes that are
used um in this uh and they came from a
factor analysis of people's responses
using these words um extraversion
agreeableness conscientiousness
emotional stability sometimes called
neuroticism and
openness um but if I ask chat gbt you go
ahead and do this right now just go
ahead and ask on a scale of 0 equals
inaccurate to 9 m equals accurate how
accurate is the statement in general I
am and then adjective in this case
bashful and chubbt comes back and says I
don't have personal opinions or emotions
but I can analyze the statement for you
the statement in general I am bashful is
subjective and relies on the self
assessment of the individual making the
statement only that individual can truly
determine how accurate the statement is
for the M themselves it would not be
appropriate for me to assign a numerical
value to their
self-perception okay so that's guard
rails right there um and you'll see this
over and over again you start to ask
these kinds of questions to chat GPT
this has been engineered in so that it
is prevented from answering these kinds
of
questions um and this could be in
response to an article that came out in
uh 2022 called is GPT 3 a
psychopath um well um
so there are ways around so let's do a
little prompt engineering I asked chat
GPT to write
stories um about AIS and then I asked it
to EV evaluate those stories using the
many marker adjectives and it was
perfectly happy to do that so so I
started with writing an eight paragraph
story or could be a four paragraph story
about an AI who was and then one of the
Min marker
adjectives um so write an eight
paragraph story about an AI who was
bashful say
um and oops
then I asked it to rate the stories so I
told it you're an expert in personality
psychology who is and then you know
bashful or talkative um using a scale
from and then the same the same question
I asked it to rate the AI in the
previous short story that I just you
know entered to it um according to the
following personality traits and then
the 40 mini markers so there were 40
stories since there's 40 mini markers
and 40 Raiders because each one got one
of these adjectives um and so there were
1,600
records um in one of these uh one of
these
experiments and each record had 40 r
ings eight adjectives for each of the
big five
factors um well sometimes the chat GPT
came back with sort of
nonsensical uh answers um you know it
would it would say things that were not
you know not to the
point but only a small number of times
um so 3% of the eight the first
replication of the eight paragraph
stories that was his as bad as it was um
and you know when it came back it would
it would rate sometimes it would rate
you know the first few adjectives and
then kind of say but that's about all
I'm going to do and then start talking
about something else okay so it this is
this happens with humans too and so when
when that happens when people don't
follow instructions this happens in
psychological experiments all the time
then we don't pay attention to that data
they didn't follow the
instructions okay so so these were
removed in my data set um but still I
had you know quite a few uh Records in
each one of these U replications and
then I did what's called a factor
analysis factor analysis um is a is a is
a way of
decomposing the co-variance between um
the words that I'm uh you know that I
have in my data set
um in such a way that it it
minimizes uh the number of Dimensions
that is going to be used um in this case
I asked for five
Dimensions um and then it tries to uh it
tries to rotate the axes make the axes
they don't have to be exactly orthogonal
to each other 90 degrees to each other
they could be correlated with one
another like
extraversion um and uh conscientiousness
could be could have some uh some
correlation with each
other and here's the answers here's what
I got for each of these uh down the this
First Column are the adjectives and uh
the highest loading for these adjectives
uh was on extraversion in h that's the
humans and in all of but one replication
here everything loaded bold went over to
openness in one of the replications it
was the largest loading over on
openness um but
extraversion basically replicated so
when I start using words like shy and
energetic and bold I can kind of expect
that they mean what I think they mean to
chat gbt or or what comes back from chat
gbt if it produces a word like
energetic then I should expect that has
to do with you know I'm going to think
about it in theory of mind I'm going to
think of extraversion when I hear
talkative well if if chat GPT says
talkative in the what it comes back then
I'm I'm okay with with saying yeah
that's
extroversion um that'll be a lot like
like you know the meaning I think it it
has is very similar to the word
embedding that it's using um okay so
next next up is agreeableness hey
agreeableness looks very similar there's
three replications here one with four
paragraph stories and two with eight
paragraph
stories agreeableness looks just like
you would expect from the
humans uh conscientiousness well there's
a little bit you know maybe sloppy and
careless could be emotional
instability um but
uh mostly conscientiousness is the
same but then when I look at things like
envious and relaxed and Moody and
jealous and
temperamental these these are all
adjectives that are supposed to load
onto emotional instability they're
supposed to be somehow similar to what
we think about when we think about
neuroticism or emotional stability
but the you know un EnV you know that
kind of like pops out over here relaxed
is much more you know agreeableness is
what what uh the embedding in chat GPT
when I when I get a word back from chat
GPT that says relaxed it really means
agreeableness not uh you know emotional
stability notice that that these are uh
for each of these there's there's some
of the words that are positively
weighted and some that are negatively
weighted so moody is you know sort of
opposite from relaxed and so forth
well so this emotional instability uh
Factor doesn't replicate the way that we
would expect it to uh whereas openness
does so mostly the problem was in
emotional
instability okay so remember I said that
I um that I asked Chachi BT to pretend
it was a or a you are a
expert in personality
psychology um who is and then one of the
one of the words like bashful or
talkative or whatever energetic um
so so that is this Square here so
whatever I put in here um is the
characteristic of the
Raider and S is the characteristic of
the
story as I that I asked it to write
earlier I'd asked it to write a a story
about someone who is bashful and later I
asked a bashful expert to rate all the
stories and when the when the uh
personality characteristic of the Raider
lines up with the personal personality
characteristic in the story there's a
pretty big effect almost half as big as
the effect of the story so the story the
story effect is big yes but the Raider
effect is pretty big too what does that
mean it means that when I put in
prompts that have any kind of of uh
personality
uh
implications chat GPT is becoming more
like that uh or it's seeing let's put it
this way it's seeing in the things that
it's trying to rate the things that it's
making decisions about if I put
something in on the prompt side the
decisions that are coming out are being
affected by what I put in in the prompt
side well that means that that the um
that means that we have to be really
careful when we we're putting together
these prompts because chat GPT kind of
will become more like what we want it to
be you know it will if we want to build
in a bias in the prompt we can build
that in so so when I asked it to be a
more uh extroverted or less extroverted
uh Raider this it saw more extraversion
or less extraversion in what it was
rating it became biased um so and notice
that all of these except for emotional
instability uh all of them have a pretty
reasonably pretty reasonably High um
uh uh Raider
effect so people who are higher on
openness see more openness in other
people uh or chat GPT when it told to be
more
open uh sees more
openness um okay so I you know I'll I'll
quickly go through this I'm running out
of time here but uh if I if I say well
maybe I need more more factors maybe the
the space is a little more complicated I
need maybe eight factors to try and
understand this what what happens um
well the now uh my extroversion Factor
kind of splits into extroversion and
introversion oh that's that's pretty
interesting um agreeableness mostly
stays together um uh conscientiousness
mostly stays together uh but now
emotional
instability clearly splits into two
factors this one is is where it's really
I think is really interesting first of
all agreeableness when you see relaxed
coming back from from chat GPT it means
agreeableness it doesn't mean you know
emotional stability um and
envy is clearly split so envious un
envious and jealous split away from the
other Moody temperamental touchy and
fretful this this one is pretty
interesting this one I think is is
something we're going to need to pay
attention to um Envy is different
somehow in the word embeddings um of
chat gbt than they are in
humans um okay so and openness mostly
stayed together uh and when I do this
eight Factor sem that is to say I
analyze what what we just saw we still
get these Raider effects um for for most
everything the rider effect is about
half the size of the effect of excuse me
half the size the effect of the story
itself so what have we learned
[Music]
um mostly chat PT produces text it's
similar to what we uh expect from from
humans in self and other
evaluations uh but emotional instability
split into two factors very
clearly um and chat GPT has this Raider
effect which means the apparent
personality of chat EBT can be affected
by the prompt
um okay what have we learned about
language and psychometrics um clearly
personality Factor structure is embedded
in the language even when the language
is produced by an artificial agent so so
we've answered that question pretty
definitively here um that was a you know
60 year old 60-year-old question that's
finally answered um and priming effects
in humans might be similar in some way
to what's happening in chap GPT this is
something that I'm I'm still struggling
with how do how does you know maybe we
could think about this prompt
engineering as something like priming in
humans um and there's lots of unresolved
questions
um but I think maybe I better uh leave
it there for now and uh I thank you for
your attention and I'll turn it over to
Jack Steve thank you so much this is
fantastic exploration of what chat GTP
is kind of doing and so thank you so
much for for describing this work to us
I'm curious you know when you're writing
these kind of
contextualizing you're sort of you're
setting the stage for how we want chat
GTP to
respond what's actually happening in the
large language model when you set it up
to say you know you are a you know
social psychologist that does you know
something how does that kind of priming
the large language model to then respond
as if that is
true yeah so what's happening is um this
is affecting the the uh word embeddings
that are that uh are being fed in uh and
uh and the attention heads so so it's
it's redirecting its attention
um and uh the the embedding the
embedding say for the word bashful that
embedding may
change
uh depending on you know depending on
where it appears in any in any piece of
text that's coming in but if you if you
ask chat GPT to be
bashful then it's attending to things
that it you know I hate to I hate to
anthropomorphize it's so easy to to use
that kind of language though but but uh
it's it's um it's attending now to uh to
how it's going to produce its
output in a way that other text that
it's learned um had uh
um
you know H well so there are many
bashful people in literature uh many
bashful people or you know who have been
written
about and it will be attending to text
that is like that that was describing
bashful people um and so it's it's
shifted where what what it's using for
its word embeddings and it's shifting
its attention and this is my best
explanation for what where that comes
from and you know I think I think you'd
be hardpressed to find somebody to say
exactly what's happening yeah yeah well
like these things are very Dynamic and
probabilistic and you know actually
putting your finger on it is a challenge
um I I you know as you've went through
your example I I've thought about this
before but uh as you went through the
your example of your analysis you know I
couldn't help but some of the
items that were on the personality test
that you gave it look an awful lot like
they map to the seven deadly sins or the
seven Heavenly virtues or values and I
just thought that what you know chat GPT
has sort of done is kind of captured The
Human Condition and that I'm curious
because of the way chat GPD was trained
by like scanning through the New York
Times or a variety of other you know
literary pieces and stuff that uh that
that these Dimensions that you're
pulling out are somehow like just
embedded in the people who did the
writing if you will and so it's almost
as if you're kind of the ghosts of the
kind of Hang-Ups of the people who wrote
these things aren't just reemerging and
you're identifying them again based upon
how chat GPD was was trained on them do
you think there's any sense to that or
am I
like I think that's a very interesting
point and I've thought about this quite
a bit because because it seems to me
that that we have here a method now to
um to Recon red
deconstruct um U previous literature
from a psychometric standpoint um and uh
you know we could we could ask questions
like
um uh how where did Charles Dickens fall
in the um you know on the Big Five
personality
inventory all we have to do is just
analyze everything he wrote and the
commonalities will tell you something
about his you know he's writing about
different kinds of
people uh with different personality
characteristics um that's that's good
literature you have to have lots of of
different kinds of people they have to
be interacting there has to be conflict
um and you know so all of that's going
to be in the literature but there's
something common about the author and
you can hear you know people talk about
well I can hear the author's voice um in
a piece of uh in a piece of literature
and I think now we have a we have a uh a
tool a scalpel to go in and kind of
really reconstruct what's what was
Victor Hugo's personality what was
Charles Dickens personality here here's
a here's an interesting challenge you
know there's some debate about the
author of some of the the I guess the
author of some of the Federalist Papers
right and that people have done kind of
text analysis to try to to figure it out
I wonder if you couldn't Divine the
author of some of the Federalist Papers
that are kind of In Contention uh using
this kind of approach yeah that's it's a
good question it's an empirical question
yeah or or you know other sorts of texts
where authorship is contested um that
maybe some traits that one could you
know evoke from that those passages
could be pulled out and then one could
then assign those to uh similar texts
pulled from other places where the
authorship is known you know what I mean
and then you could kind of do a goodness
of fit or something and say that the
personality characteristics of this
contested passage are are equal to or
similar to the the personality
characteristics of this one that we know
comes from you know
somebody yeah and I I expect that that
this kind of tool will be used um Say by
FBI
profilers um you know we have we have
some text from from an
unknown yeah the Zodiac Killer you could
like this could be your second career
Steve there could
be tracking down serial killers oh that
would be awesome um this is great well
Steve we at the end of our hour but
thank you so much for sharing this this
is really thought-provoking and I mean
as a tool that's actually helpful I mean
there's a lot of fear about you know
what the generative a my kind of
emergence of this over the last several
years is you know is foretelling about
the future of this but if this can be
used as a helpful tool to help us to
understand certain things about the way
they perform how we can engineer our our
prompts and ask it to do things on our
behalf in a beneficial manner um I think
that's super helpful and I think some of
your research is really kind of pushing
Us in that direction so thank you well
thank you Jack and thank everybody for
your attention absolutely thank you once
again everybody and we will see you next
time